entre deux affaires de conduite sans
permis de gilet jaune était convoqué
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal
correctionnel
une procédure simplifiée dite de rcpc ou
plaidé coupable pour une infraction au
code de la route
kevin bada et gaëlle perron ont
participé le 13 décembre dernier au
blocage des entrepôts d'un supermarché à
saint vith des faits qui l'ont reconnu
mais ce jour là elles étaient une
trentaine sur le rond point et seulement
2 à répondre on n'a pas bloqué de
voiture on ajuste bloqué des camions on
était devant un entrepôt
je trouve ça injuste que ce soit
monsieur perrault et moi qu'ils soient
qui sont condamnables qui disent
représenter devant un procureur quoi
c'est on essaie de nous faire taire j'ai
l'impression après match et nos maux
seulement voilà non c'est nous
déterminent d'autant plus on ne lâchera
rien ça c'est clair et net
c'est clair et net on restera dans le
cadre légal autant possible pas de
procès donc pas de débat contradictoire
dans ce type de procédure de
consentement les faits puisqu'ils sont
reconnus ne sont qu exposer brièvement
et à huis clos une justice rapide pour
des cas simples ici une question
centrale restera donc en suspens dans
cette procédure il est indiqué que à
tort ou à raison
ils apparaissent comme étant quelque
part un peu des meneurs je mets ce terme
entre guillemets parce que c'est une
qualification non objective mais qui
pose question puisque effectivement on a
le sentiment et je parle bien d'un
sentiment qu'on cible un petit peu de
personnes un petit peu pour faire
exemple 400 euros damende pour l'un 400
dont 200 avec sursis pour l'autre
des sommes qui devraient être couvertes
par l'organisation de collectes kevin
benda égale perron perdront également
six points sur leur permis de conduire